checks.
Our Gary Tuchman went to amish
country to learn more about the
allegations.
>> We've told this amish dairy
farmer in Pennsylvania will
protect his identity.
As a father of ten, who we will
call Fred, tells us the story
of a man who came to his house
over five years ago to buy
puppies.
Fred breeds it as a side job.
>> He seemed uncomfortable and
nervous and fidgety.
That's when I started getting
suspicious.
>> His instinct was correct.
These are nine checks from
November 2017.
The name on each of them,
George Santos.
The checks to by puppies
obtained by CNN were written to
Fred and other amish dog
breeders.
They totaled more than 50,000
dollar.
Fred says the man he then U.S.
George came with a female
assistant.
They cut their deal in this
very room we are standing, in
the milk house.
He says the man wanted two
German shepherds.
>> He says, okay, we will take
that puppy and that puppy.
His assistant grabs the two
puppies.
He takes them out the door.
He pulls out a check.
I was like, oh no, is this guy
going to pay me with a check?
By then, I was very suspicious.
>> You told me before, she put
the dogs in the car, correct?
>> Right.
>> Before they paid?
>> You are suspicious because
he is going to pay with that
check.
You don't take checks.
>> I told him I don't take
checks, all I can take is cash.
He said, would you expect me to
carry enough cash to buy a
bunch of puppies on a trip like
this?
I do not have cash.
The only thing I can give you
is the check.
Well, I thought to myself, it
looks like I am dumb.
>> I'm stuck.
>> The dogs are in the car.
>> You thought they pulled a
fast?
One >> It was obvious to me by
that time that he probably
pulled a fast one.
>> So you said, through the
goodness of your heart, I take
it, that you will take the
check.
>> I said, I decided the check
is better than nothing.
I will give it a try.
>> The result of that dry?
>> The check bounced.
>> Then you are charged a fee
for depositing a bounced check.
>> Right.
>> Have you gotten the money
back?
>> No.
>> Have you heard from anybody?
>> Mr. Santos?
>> Just three days after these
puppies were purpose, Santos
participated in an adoption
event at a store in Staten
Island, New York, according to
a former owner of the business.
That man, Daniel, tells CNN he
wrote a check for a few hundred
dollars to Santos's past rescue
charity following the event,
but he saw his check online and
someone crossed out the charity
name and wrote Anthony, and
other name Santos has used.
>> We have received no comment
from Santos or his attorney
regarding all this.
Santos was ultimately charged
with theft by Pennsylvania 30s,
but the charges were later
dropped after Santos made a
claim somebody had stolen his
checkbook, according to a
lawyer who was a former friend
of his.
That lawyer, Tiffany, says she
no longer believes him.
>> He's definitely, you know,
not qualified to be where he is
in congress.
He should really be in jail.
>> This is George Santos?
>> Right.
>> Do you believe this is the
man who bought your dog and put
them in the car and took him
away?
>> I feel it is, based on my
memory, I would say yes it is.
>> Fred loves dogs.
He breeds others.
He has tried his best to forget
about being foisted.